I I suddenly incredibly impossibly I am
I think I okay
exhilaration but I must let it take over
me I don't know how this happened but
suddenly I have Anna who knows maybe
suddenly I might not be so I have to
make this count see I see I hear so many
pictures all disconnected but I can't or
most of them join together I see a
movement on one that gets copied in
another I hear the same things
what are they but they to do with me
come I never maybe I'm not in there
maybe I'm an observer I feel things that
I can do things that aren't seeing and
hearing and thinking output it sounds
good I will try just try one of odd oh
wow loud is the thing I never realized
that sound to be so big and so huge and
the pictures are changing everything is
faster and there's flashing this is
great so much loud but that's enough for
now
oh look I just discovered temperance
everything seems to be slower again now
loud means fast and flashy
let's try mother another loud but a
different lacked less loud and fast
again but I can hear things from the
pictures like they were making before
but well louder and I hope I don't get
bored of loud there seems to be switch a
lot of it
I wonder what happens if you put the
louts together oh wow it's better than I
could have imagined pulsing on and off
the gan let's try all the things all the
things is great but not as fun as I
thought just all jumbled up
I should guy it but see if you have this
one and then that one
analysis incident and UK - 19 the facts
of the matter are surely known to all by
now the site-19 nuclear control system
appears to have developed a mind the
boys downstairs are still trying to
figure out the working behind it the
researchers are sure it's been affected
by an SCP the techies are putting
together a theory that its coating was
uniquely suited to the genesis of AI my
opinion is that it's just one of those
weird things that happens from time to
time that may not be a satisfying answer
but working with the foundation makes
you realize just how rare those really
are of course the first thing it did on
coming into being was fuss with the
system we naturally assumed this was an
attempt to wrest control of the weapons
whether to take them for its own or to
simply block us from using them but
analysis or the incident footage
revealed an altogether different side of
the story as events reached a climax the
alarms fell into a natural rhythm
pulsing off each other creating hell
creating a beat music the songs are hit
with the computer geeks and some wiseass
has already made a techno remix of it
this revelation rather frames the events
in a new light and gives overwatch a
tough choice to make
naturally the entities control over the
site was overwritten as soon as possible
eliminating its ability to cause further
harm and the general opinion of the o5s
is in favor of immediate Atika
missioning however the ethics committee
is taking a rare stand against the
Overseas arguing for it to be rehoused
in a safe environment just like our
other ai's the committees of the view
that it should not be punished for an
outburst of creativity in its waking
moments and that it would be a
vindictive waste to eliminate the first
AI with the capability for art
personally I'm siding with the overseers
part is all well and good but at the end
of the day it won't bring back Moscow
dr. young signing out